( intro music )
There used to be more
than 4,000 elephants
in the greater Gorongosa area.
And during the war
most of those elephants
were killed.
Hungry soldiers ate their meat.
And traded their ivory
for guns and ammunition.
When it was all over
there was only a few
hundred traumatized
elephants left in the park.
People spoke of being charged
and chased by elephants.
And having terrible
experiences with them.
And, having spent a lot of
time in my life with elephants
I thought, "Well,
maybe by running away
under those circumstances that
the people were provoking
the elephants to charge."
I talked to my sister,
Joyce, about it
who by then had become
probably the worlds
leading expert on
wild African elephant behavior.
And she agreed.
So, she came to Gorongosa
to see for herself.
The first thing
she had to do was
identify elephants
in the population.
And that meant taking
photographs and then video
so that she could
study their behavior.
We both agreed that
we wouldn't run away from
charging elephants.
And so I built this metal frame
for my Land Rover,
to protect us.
If I was wrong about the
charging elephants.
( audience laughter )
And, one day I was
out with Greg Carr
and a ranger named Maveneco
And the elephants were eating
these Acacia Albida seed pods
they are like candy
for the elephants.
They just love them,
and they were
busy eating those
things and
eating all around the car
while the babies played
and it was absolute magic.
We never had
an experience
like this in Gorongosa
with elephants.
And, soon...
or later the elephants
moved on and it was late
and we had a long way to go
back to park headquarters.
And on our way
an elephant had knocked this
tree down, across the road.
And it was just
starting to get dark.
And so I flicked
my lights on and
I bashed my way through the
forest around the tree.
And suddenly I heard elephants
trumpeting on my left.
And I looked up to see
three big adult females
charging straight at me.
And so, I switched off the
car and we all sat quietly
while one of the
elephants came forward.
And she towered above the car.
And she raised her trunk
and she smelled us.
And she gazed down at
us through the bars
of the open vehicle.
I wasn't too worried though
because it was normal.
You know, it was only
a matter of time
before she'd just
back slowly away
and join the rest of the
herd and we'd be free to go.
But she didn't.
She just stood there.
And time passed and I started
to worry a little bit.
And then suddenly she
lowered her head
and with the full
force of her body
she slammed into the
front of the car.
She hit so hard that
she blew the tire off the rim
on the other side.
( audience chuckles )
And the protective body armor
and the vehicle panels
just collapsed.
And simultaneously
I heard this bang go off.
And I didn't realize until later
it was the sound of
Maveneco's .458
which is a
huge caliber rifle.
You know,
the bullets are like this.
It's an enormously loud noise.
And the elephant backed away.
He shot a warning
shot over her head
and she backed away.
I thought it would
be a good idea
to give her some
more space.
So, I turned the car on and
I backed up a little bit.
At which point she put her
head down and charged again
and this time straight
between the headlights.
And with my hands on the
wheel she drove us backward
with her head pressing against
the bars in front of me
and they buckled.
I kept trying to steer the car.
But I had zero control.
I didn't want her
to spin us sideways
where we would easily flip
and she'd just pummel us.
But she drove us backwards
and we slammed into a tree
at which point
Maveneco shot another...
shot at point blank
over her head.
And she backed away again,
this time into the forest.
So, I pulled the car
back out onto the track
and we jumped out to
try to change the tire.
At which point she
charged again...
( audience laughter )
And Maveneco fired
his last warning shot.
They're given
three warning shots.
Luckily she never came back.
My car was a wreck.
( audience laughter )
But the bars had held
and no one got hurt.
I was devastated though.
My confidence with the elephants
was completely shattered.
And I was no longer
willing to hold my ground
against charging elephants.